hi I'm Brett Martin CEO and co-founder
of sin are basically the fall behind
sonar is for the past 10 years we've
been uploading our identity who our
friends are what bands we like what food
we like to the internet right and now
with the mobile revolution we're
downloading all that information and it
sits in our pocket so sonar is about
unlocking the value of all that
information that we spent you know
putting online about ourselves and
helping you unlock that value and use it
to connect with people right here right
now someone has sonar they're in a
coffee shop and it turns out that two
seats away there's a girl that's a
friend of their friend from college or
maybe they went to the same school they
both went to Georgetown together you
know that person can just with one click
of a button reach out and send a tweet
hey you know hey Jenny I saw that you
also went to Georgetown you know I'm a
2004 she'll see that and respond back
and they can have coffee together so you
know we see a future where it's actually
less awkward to talk to the person
sitting next to you than it is to sit
there in silence